[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'étais en train d'écrire mon texte pour
cette ADIX quand je réalise que mon
logiciel Word souligne le mot mais ta
vert il ne le reconnaît pas
alors je me dis ouh là je m'apprête à
parler à des centaines de personnes d'un
mot qui n'existe pas
avec elle est-ce que c'est vraiment ce
que tu souhaites pour ton début de
carrière comme je ne chercheuse alors on
essaie je suis enseignante chercheuse en
informatique moi qui aime le théâtre
j'en doute dans ma vie plusieurs rôles
un jour je mets ma blouse blanche et
j'effectue des recherches dans un
laboratoire l'autre je transmets mes
connaissances aux étudiants aujourd'hui
j'enfile encore un autre costume en
venant vous parler du métaver alors j'ai
pas forcément la tenue stéréotypée du
Geek j'ai pas de lunettes carrées de
chemise à carreaux en plus je suis une
femme
pour couronner le tout j'étais même pas
né quand le métal vert a été inventé et
oui contre les idées reçues le métaver
n'est pas interven nouveau mais était
introduit en 92 par Nails Stephenson un
auteur de science-fiction
en fait au même titre que beaucoup
d'avancés scientifiques le mettent un
verre est un concept qui naît de la
science-fiction et que beaucoup de
personnes utilisent aujourd'hui pour
décrire ce qui serait le successeur de
l'Internet actuel alors je vous vois
venir
en quoi ça me concerne j'ai déjà du mal
à faire ma déclaration d'impôts en ligne
c'est bon
pourtant le métal vert concerne tout le
monde et surtout peut être bénéfique à
tous bon pour comprendre il faut que je
vous décrive un peu ce que c'est et
notez ici que je parle du métaver au
singulier c'est parce qu'en fait je
parle du concept du métaver mais en
réalité il n'en existe pas un seul mais
une multitude en gros on peut le décrire
comme un réseau d'environnement virtuel
actif en permanence dans lequel
nombreuses personnes peuvent se
connecter et interagir entre elles
et l'aspect persistant du métavère est
important c'est le monde virtuel si vous
ne vous y connectez pas il continue sans
vous un peu comme un jeu vidéo dans
lequel on pourrait jamais appuyer sur
pause et certains d'entre vous sont
peut-être d'ailleurs familiers avec les
jeux ce qu'on life ou World of Warcraft
qui sont eux-mêmes et formes de Métavers
moi quand j'étais ado j'ai passé pas mal
de temps dans un méta vert peut-être un
des moins connus qui s'appelait shimbos
alors ce qui est drôle c'est qu'à
l'époque c'est une Bose on appelait pas
ça du tout un méta vert c'était plus une
sorte de chat en ligne évolué on pouvait
se connecter à mon numérique sur
l'ordinateur un petit personnage aussi
appelé avatar nous représentait et on
pouvait découvrir un univers fantastique
tout en discutant avec des inconnus et
en faisant quelques jeux
c'est difficile de vous décrire
aujourd'hui ce qui m'attirait dans ce
monde alternatif dans la vie réelle
j'étais bien entourée d'amis de ma
famille mais dans ce monde parallèle il
y avait une forme de liberté celle de
parler à des gens de la France entière
ou juste de s'évader un peu du quotidien
en fait quand j'y repense je réalise que
j'étais quand même un peu à l'époque
pourtant ça m'a pris des années avant de
découvrir que ma vocation c'était
l'informatique et quelques années de
plus avant de découvrir ce qu'elle est
devenue le cœur de mes recherches la
réalité virtuelle
alors ce qui est amusant c'est
qu'aujourd'hui si on entend beaucoup
parler du métaver c'est notamment lié à
la réalité virtuelle alors non pas parce
que c'est nouveau car elle date des
années 70 mais grâce à sa
démocratisation avec des casques de
réalité virtuelle parfois moins cher que
certains smartphones
bon c'est aussi à cause du coût
marketing d'une marque ayant récemment
changé de nom on va pas se mentir
mais alors qu'est-ce qu'elle apporte au
métal vert la réalité virtuelle parce
qu'en fait le métabère on peut
l'utiliser sans cette technologie on
peut s'y connecter grâce à un ordinateur
un smartphone c'est déplacer avec le
clavier
mais lorsque vous enfilez un casque de
réalité virtuelle ce monde que vous
regardiez sur votre écran vous pouvez
maintenant être totalement immergé
dedans et c'est avatar qui vous
représentait vous pouvez désormais faire
corps avec ce dernier
et pour cette raison les avatars sont à
manger très important dans le métal vert
alors je sais pas si vous aimez vous
déguiser mais moi vous l'aurez compris
j'adore mettre des costumes
on peut voir le méta vert comme une
grande pièce de théâtre où chaque
importe le costume qu'il souhaite que
l'on veuille un avatar féminin masculin
jeune vieux humain ou pas tout est
possible et pour certains c'est une
vraie libération de pouvoir choisir une
apparence au plus proche de leur
identité et de pouvoir interagir dans un
contexte où il serait plus en phase avec
eux-mêmes pour d'autres il s'agit même
d'une opportunité pour dépasser ses
limites personnelles comme la timidité
moi même je suis plutôt timide lorsque
je passe parle pardon vous voyez face à
un public si je vous parlais là à
travers un avatar je pourrais en
profiter pour cacher mes tics de
névrosité
estomper pourquoi pas mes cernes et puis
afficher un grand sourire non
heureusement j'ai pas besoin d'Avatar
pour ça
mais c'est pas tout les avatars
permettent de faire des choses
fascinantes en réalité virtuelle et
notamment de vivre des choses qu'il ne
serait pas possible de vivre dans le
monde réel
par exemple dans mes recherches j'ai
réalisé une expérience où j'ai mis deux
personnes dans un même avatar c'est
comme si vous partagiez votre corps avec
quelqu'un d'autre et grâce à ça j'ai
découvert que lorsqu'un utilisateur voit
ses bras virtuelles bouger alors que
c'est l'autre utilisateur qui les
contrôle il peut quand même avoir
l'impression d'être à l'origine du
mouvement
et ça c'est vraiment intéressant pour de
la formation à des gestes techniques ou
de la rééducation motrice
en effet que ce soit dans la formation
ou dans le médical le métavère peut
avoir des bénéfices conséquents un autre
exemple mon père était médecin
urgentiste c'est une profession où l'on
voit des cas très différents et on peut
faire face à des situations très
stressantes dans ce contexte grâce à des
scénarios variés et rejouables la
réalité virtuelle permet des formations
pardon et des mises en situation
réaliste beaucoup moins coûteuses et
compliquées
mais il y a aussi beaucoup d'implication
dans le cadre des thérapies médicales et
psychologiques on sait aujourd'hui
qu'une exposition en réalité virtuelle
permet de modifier le comportement des
gens comme dans le traitement des
phobies par exemple mais aussi dans le
cadre de thérapie pour les troubles du
comportement alimentaire on fait se
regarder des patients dans un miroir
virtuel tout en modulant la morphologie
de leur avatar
bon cependant ces applications sortent
un peu de la vision dominante actuelle
du métaver en effet les grands
industriels du domaine envisagent
surtout le métaver pour réaliser des
actions de la vie quotidienne et
notamment des choses qui ont réalisé
déjà avec Internet comme parler à nos
proches ou réaliser des achats
et oui
un aspect important du métavère et la
monétisation et non sans surprise
lorsqu'on regarde les grandes
entreprises actrices du phénomène alors
dans le genre un ami a récemment acheté
dans le méta vert une licorne
alors pour les connaisseurs non je ne
parle pas d'une start-up je parle d'un
cheval un vrai cheval avec une corne et
en plus de ça il se fait de l'argent
grâce à des courses de chevaux virtuels
alors c'est quand même un peu absurde
même si bon c'est peut-être mieux que de
vraies courses de chevaux je ne sais pas
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que l'aspect
commercial du metavère si l'on séduit
certains il fait peur à d'autres et je
comprends moi-même je suis pas fan c'est
comme si la société de consommation
n'était pas assez importante qu'il
fallait en plus acheter des choses qui
n'existent pas
pour autant je pense qu'il ne faut pas
rester sur ce sentiment de peur et ne
pas oublier que le méta vert on peut en
profiter sans pour autant dépenser de
l'argent juste pour en apprécier les
avantages
un autre exemple la pandémie a
clairement mis en avant un autre
bénéfice du metaves ou en étant bloqué
chez soi isolé on pouvait quand même en
se connectant à certaines plateformes
avoir l'impression d'avoir passé un
moment avec nos proches
et moi-même ne pouvant voyager pendant
cette période j'ai assisté à des
conférences en réalité virtuelle me
permettant au passage de faire des
économies financières et de réduire mon
empreinte carbone mais en plus c'était
beaucoup plus immersif qu'avec des
simples appels visioconférence j'ai pu
sur ces plateformes croisées par hasard
des chercheurs du monde entier faire du
bateau virtuel boire un apéro virtuel
avec des femmes chercheuses de ma
communauté
en buvant du vrai vin par contre faut
pas viser
parce que oui il y a certaines choses
que l'on n'est pas prêt à perdre en
entrant dans le méta vert car la réalité
virtuelle reste encore limitée sur
certains aspects et notamment dans les
sens quel stimule
alors ces derniers temps beaucoup de
vous ont expérimenté la perte de
certains sens
le goût et l'odorat ça doit vous dire
quelque chose pas top
et bien en réalité virtuelle c'est un
peu pareil il y a des sens qui se
perdent la vue est très exploitée Louis
également mais le toucher le contact si
présent dans nos vies sont beaucoup plus
difficiles à transpirer en réalité
virtuelle tout comme le goût et l'odorat
il y a néanmoins de plus en plus de
recherches qui explorent ces défis Aline
rihann par exemple des chercheurs ont
développé un système qui permet de
donner une sensation tactile cohérente
dans la main lorsque l'on cueille une
pomme virtuelle
par contre donnez l'impression de
croquer dans la pomme et faire ressentir
son goût on en est encore loin
mais en fait c'est pas grave le but
n'est pas non plus de passer 100% de son
temps dans le métaver et puis bah si on
veut se nourrir il vaut mieux manger une
vraie pomme en fait
le met à vert n'a pas vocation à
remplacer la réalité même si on sait
qu'il y a toujours le risque à certaines
dérives pour ça il y a déjà des
chercheurs qui explorent les potentiels
conséquences sanitaires du métaver comme
avec les risques d'addiction ou les
effets il y a une exposition prolongée
sur la vision
et oui jusqu'à présent je vous ai
surtout parlé des aspects bénéfiques du
metavère mais derrière le lit d’eau le
derrière le rideau pardon il vient avec
son lot de défaut
par exemple les avatars anonymisent
totalement les utilisateurs comme si
tout le monde portait un masque alors
vous imaginez sortir faire vos courses
et tout le monde porte un masque
alors oui vous avez expérimenté ça dans
la pandémie mais je parle pas de
celui-là
le risque avec ça c'est que les gens se
sentent tout permis pouvant mener à des
risques d'harcèlement ou d'arnaque et
pour ces raisons on sait qu'il y a
encore du boulot avant que le métal vert
puisse être bien utilisé
en fait on peut dire que si le métaverte
est une grande pièce de théâtre il reste
encore en écrire les scènes et c'est en
partie le rôle des chercheurs de se
poser les bonnes questions afin d'aller
vers des métaders bénéfiques pour
l'humain et non nocifs mais c'est aussi
au rôle de tous les citoyens de
s'emparer du phénomène que ce soit en se
familiarisant avec lui en y effectuant
une utilisation bienveillante et
pourquoi pas même en contribuant à la
recherche en participant à des études
utilisateurs
alors qu'en pensez-vous vous voulez vous
rester spectateur du metavers ou devenir
acteur de son évolution je vous laisse y
réfléchir faut que j'aille nourrir ma
licorne merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]